we're continuing to learn more and more
about
um the uh proximity the
the proximity to a coup that took place
with donald trump
uh in those late days of his
administration i don't want to spend a
lot of time on this but indeed we are we
are learning that that coup was much
closer than we thought
much of this relates to statements by
general mark milley that we now
know about because of the book from
carol lennon and philip rucker
report from cnn the top u.s military
officer
chairman of the joint chiefs general
mark milley was so shaken that then
president donald trump and his allies
might attempt to coup or take other
dangerous or illegal measures after the
november election
that millie and other top officials
informally planned
for different ways to stop trump
according to excerpts of an upcoming
book
obtained by cnn they were so worried
they actually got together and said
how do we stop a trump coup if he
attempts it um
it was a kind of saturday night massacre
in reverse lennog and rucker write
the book describes how millie and other
joint chiefs discussed
a plan to resign one by one rather than
carry out orders from trump
that they consider to be illegal
dangerous or ill-advised
this is absolutely incredible the book
recounts
the book recounts how for the first time
in modern us history
the nation's top military officer whose
role is to advise the president
was preparing for a showdown with the
commander-in-chief because he feared a
coup attempt after trump lost the
november election
the author explained the authors
explained millie's growing concerns that
personnel moves that put trump acolytes
in positions of power at the pentagon
after the election including the firing
of defense secretary mark esper
and the resignation of attorney general
william barr were the sign of something
sinister to come
milly spoke to friends lawmakers and
colleagues about the threat of a coup
and the joint chiefs chairman felt he
had to be on guard for what might come
quote they may try but they're not going
to effing succeed
milly told his deputies you can't do
this without the military
you can't do this without the cia and
the fbi we are the guys with the guns
this is how much those
at the centers of power feared that this
was what donald trump was going to
attempt to do
now donald trump reacted to this report
and put out a statement
saying despite massive voter fraud and
irregularities during the 2020
presidential election scam that we are
now seeing play out in very big and
important states
i never threatened or spoke about to
anyone a coup of our government
so ridiculous sorry to inform you but an
election is my form of coup
and if i was going to do a coup one of
the last people i would want to do it
with is general mark milley
he got his job only because the world's
most overrated general james mattis
could not stand him
had no respect for him and would not
recommend him to me the fact that mattis
didn't like him just like obama didn't
like him and actually fired millie was a
good thing
not a bad thing trump going on to say in
any event i lost respect for millie
when we walked together to st john's
church which was still
smoldering from a radical liberal
radical left fire set the day before
side by side
and the following day millie choked like
a dog
in front of the fake news when they told
him they thought he should not have been
walking with the president which turned
out to be incorrect
he apologized profusely on and on
um certainly not the type of person i
would be talking
coo with i'm not into coups
so what's fascinating about this is that
trump did seem to want a coup
it just seems maybe he wasn't planning
to use the military but millie's larger
point was correct which was trump and
the movement
tried to subvert the election through
potentially illegal and violent means
it's horrifying
it's absolutely dystopian and uh
the the the real coup attempt was
saying you won an election you lost and
sending lawyers around
even incompetent ones like rudy giuliani
and sydney powell and jenna ellis
to try to steal it back that's the
horrifying reality
he tried it he would try it again and
the fact that he lost
or wasn't able to do it is why he's now
using this language but absolutely crazy
stuff
i actually do plan to read this book i
alone can fix it i
i never read these types of books i
didn't read the woodward ones i didn't
read the michael wolfe ones i just have
so much other stuff history sociology
philosophy
on my my stack of books to read but the
lennig
rucker book seems very much worth
reading and they're typically quick
reads so i do plan to check it out